didn't know listen if you guys were
wanting to get some people to see this
let them know we have upon the man the
myth the legend so how you doing how you
feeling
I'm very good and bless yes yeah I mean
oh yeah so how does it feel being 78
years old today how you feeling I'm not
78 how are you
39 multiply - wow so that's where I get
my math genetics from my math genetics
comes from this part right here yeah so
how long did it take you to figure this
Instagram stuff I they got me by the way
just so you know at this mean
everybody's off it's just me you pull it
and Jennifer and a couple people not a
lot of people are on so go ahead
Instagram they Instagram Instagram
microphone and camera was off oh yeah
but I think you're too close to you too
far to the camera get a little closer
get closer you're killing me do your
thing you're moving too much
how is ty time oh I'm serious it's only
three of us and it's three that I was
waiting for you on that now everybody
that's only three of us that that 5:20
it's only the reception the reception
how did the Internet is but it's only
three of us these are old messages that
are coming up so mu Andy what are you
doing are you at the house yeah IRA -
are you gonna go what are you cooking
what I'm busy what are you cooking movie
cooking shoo uh-huh pinto beans pinto
beans yeah you get a lot of you know
coming over
you got a Mexican coming over what's her
name tell us my name I have to take you
know what's her name what's her name her
name
here we can't know by the way how's the
how's the weather in LA how you doing in
LA it's 54 and draining now it's rain
stop seriously yes before in raining
yeah you know in Dallas is like 94
degrees 90 something degrees right yeah
it's crazy
you flip so tell me do you want me to
send the jet to pick you up and bring
you here or no why don't you know why
not I'm okay you want to stay you know a
little bit get that yeah I want to bring
something with me over there you know no
no I'm okay you don't want to bring it
you know I want it are you more
comfortable how about I do this how
about I come I have an idea I think
you're gonna like this by the way there
the reception is getting lower which is
gonna make the quality better this
course 496 the higher it goes the
quality the pixels get better which is
good but I have an idea for you here's
what I'm thinking tell me what you think
how about I I mean serious I get on a
motorcycle and I come to LA I pick you
up in a big Harley you sit in the back
we come back to Dallas together me and
you and your actual trailer she is green
I will do it I'll have a real big
harley-davidson I come to LA I pick you
up we come back together to Dallas what
do you think No why not
what do you of a motorcycle you sit
behind me you hold me as a father-son we
come back there's no one in the roads
and we figure out a way to go fast no no
you have a Caesar man fever let me ask
you Jennifer's online right now poor
Jennifer Poulet family I did it private
so it's only the family and small
community let me ask you favorite movie
of all time pop favorite love story of
all time ever Fay
it sound of music and the family move
it's a beautiful and other one that's
notebook notebook and West Side Story
was I story okay
voice I story is a big love story or no
it's nice and that your favorite actress
of all time very favorite actress of all
time most beautiful actors about them we
talked about this all the time
the and were roommates give me your
favorite actress of all time beautiful
who is it I don't remember she passed
away what is her name you know her name
you can say her name I can say her name
why don't you say it
Natalie Wood's Natalie Wood by the way
she is really pretty
I'll tell you walk well let me ask Larry
6-year Natalie Wood or Rachel McAdams Oh
McAdams is good so which one is prettier
don't McAdams or Natalie Wood both of
them the same
you know macadam is great actor and
she's pretty if you're at a bar you're
35 years old Natalie Wood is on this
side Rachel McAdams is this side who are
you gonna buy a drink for for both of
them I like your strategy do you see
your capitalist capitalist you want it
all on one side and rachel mcadams on
the other side yes
the level of genius Bob I'm telling more
I think about I realize where it comes
from Betty
on a serious note your favorite place
you've ever been in your life you've
traveled you've been all over the place
your favorite memory or was it favorite
memory Paulette Jennifer are watching
favorite memory so I set the favorite
place you've been in the world Paulette
Jennifer the kids want to know your
favorite place you've been in the world
where is it
because they spend time with the fam
spend time with the family this place is
the best place so it's not mr. the place
you go to as long as your family you're
happy I'm happy
when it's happiness in a family this is
my you know no or do you know you but
happiness good talking drinking having
fun with kids this is my happiness time
happiest time yeah can you can you tell
everybody watch the one food you made
that I never liked can ask that's it
celery that's a great food you don't
know how to eat it the problem is there
the problem is the eater not the cook
the problem you have to practice next
time I came over there I'll make a
different recipe you try to sneak the
carrots in I tell I'm noticing every D
try to sneak a little bit of carrots in
your stew you make I don't like that
kind of stuff you do pop it's it's a
form of abuse you do to your son is
great food for your eyebrow man hi boss
how much thicker you want my eyebrows to
get Jennifer the other day told me babe
again we can braid your eyebrows because
my eyebrows were so long it was like a
curl it was going on dream it you can
stream it yeah you trim it I don't tons
I forget to trim it it depends if I sit
with very very wealthy clients they like
my eyebrows being longer if I'm sitting
with younger clients they want my
eyebrows shorter so it depends I try to
grow when I'm sitting man you know it
doesn't matter
so listen you miss your you miss us or
what man you haven't been here for a few
weeks you know Tico keeps talking about
you every day I miss off I miss you guys
I miss Paulette it said you know I don't
know this is any we have to wait it's
not just for us all over the world is
happening this you know and you have to
say Tom you do something
twenty years time were sleeping and Lana
yeah read a book or do something it
doesn't matter you know I asked me you
went through you were to the true war
and through this and you were there for
revolution you you seemed to I wasn't I
was a baby I was a newborn when the
revolution happened how different is the
revolution versus the war against Iraq
versus right now pandemic how different
is the are these three for you
you're not Patrick let me tell you this
please you have to prepare you have to
be prepared and ready for everything you
don't know tomorrow what's gonna happen
that's true you don't know what's gonna
happen maybe I don't know we passed
those day you were gonna roof and seed
bomb being there's a fire there was a
burning houses you know people they
didn't have a food they want to go
outside and everything this was terrible
and here same thing but my prey was that
we come in a country that they say you
know has a foundation now I don't know
what happened with this corner is gonna
be over it's not this is you know it's
happened these things is to happen you
don't know from where how but tomorrow
there is always surprises you have
always surprises life is a without the
surprises empty it's nothing you have to
have a surprise you have to prepare you
have to be ready for everything's
happening business life everything I'm
enjoying my sit with you guys sit or I
come over there I'm with the kids and
they think that tickle let's go let's go
sleep listen I know I wanna go I'm yawn
is coming okay we go to bed I go you
know passed out but he's still kicking
me hey you know this is the best thing
that they all this way with the Grace
and sure it doesn't matter but I'm
missing those all in between the reserve
you know this time I can't go
pull outside and she can't call me again
you come to parking blood and we talk
and she goes you know like this is this
life is not empty you have everything
forget about bad things just be positive
and fight for you you know we are
gladiator have you seen the movie
Gladiator one of your favorite movie
maybe what huh I've seen it maybe once
no I'm saying that's a favorite so are
you I've seen it many many times you
know I watched you yet
you see him or no kisses lagged or yours
is like okay London's no you were saying
I couldn't hear you say that one more
time so you said is beautiful but you
said glad you know we're glad you know
what we're hearing about being
gladiators we re glad you know we have
to fight for our life earn the best
things positive you're not alone you are
a family and all the ISIS on you you
know as your wife kids even to me all
the time thinking about you all over he
sees your picture and look here you can
see which we have to go press it one
okay let me see I see it the family yes
of course
this one is waiting ok I have to tell
you something what do you want to tell
you here or no yeah I'm hearing you said
you want to say something yes I got a
question for you before I let you go go
so after this whole coronavirus stuff is
over would where do you want to go what
do you want to do you've told me last
time we went to US Open I had no idea
how much you loved watching tennis what
I want to do next what you want to go
next next let's see let's see what's
gonna but give me an idea what do you
want to do next give me some kind of an
idea maybe we go to what they call that
island under Australia New Zealand no no
I learned under Australia no I got your
next Bora Bora Bora Bora
you want to go Bora Bora oh really yes I
tell you so you don't want to go Bora
Bora
I'm now I'm saying I want to go okay so
after this thing cleans up we go to Bora
Bora together okay yes yes huh how many
hours flight less than 30 minutes I mean
you will will talk it's not a long time
bora bora from l.a it's probably not
that far
somewhere between 30 minutes to 12 hours
i don't know but it's not that far
please go with the harley-davidson we
can with the with like a ship wash it we
want like a speedboat hey pop listen I
just want to tell you an happy birthday
pop I I know I tell you this all the
time but I know you can't see I can't
tell you enough times I 100%
I'm the son the man that I am because of
you I can't tell you that enough time I
love you you changed my life you are
amazing you were an incredible leader to
me you were tough but you love me and
we're very patient but you challenged
it's always when I when I sit there and
I pray and I talk to God I always tell
him how thankful I am for him have been
chosen you as my father 100% the way you
taught me was priceless and every single
second we spend time together man I am
the happiest man alive when we're
together and grandkids feel that way
Tico Dylan said I love you shiny Gracie
love you paulinho Jennifer Melba
everybody misses you wants to see you I
cannot wait I wish I was there to give
you a big hug a big kiss it's M each
kind just talking yeah you know watch
Natalie Wood and you don't know Rachel
McAdams together yeah we're over here so
I can't wait to see you I know a lot of
people send you messages everybody was
wishing you a happy birthday and I'm
glad we're getting chances to spend more
time together
next time I came over there he'll make
every player interview next time you
want to do an interview right here but
right here
yes but I ask weird questions Bob Claire
your questions though I mean I don't
have any questions before before I sit
behind that table I have to practice it
Mario will do that you will say now at
bar you're Mario's laughing on the other
side no I have to I think I can help you
with that Gabriel let me know thank you
okay Park Jun I'm glad we were able to
figure this out after a few hours but
for those that stuck around preciate you
guys for a second
sticking around and I know you got a lot
of messages when you get a chance I'm
sure you gonna give back to the people
that message you love you very much
tears very much bye bye bye bye bye